hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast
EXPEED shuttle expression of each IP one
immunogen's
for structured guided vaccine design
presented by dr. gabriel zorroski
senior research associate at the scripps
research institute in the laboratory of
and report i'm susie valdez and i will
be your moderator for today's
educational webcast
presented by labrys and sponsored by
echo clark of thermo Fisher Scientific
before we begin I'd like to remind
everyone that this is many questions as
you want and at any time during the
presentation just click on the green
question into the box that appears
the answer is many questions as we have
time for presentation also please notice
that you will be viewing this
presentation in a slide window to
enlarge the window just click on the
screen icon located on the lower right
if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing this presentation please click
on the support button at the top right
or the Q&A button please join me now in
welcoming dr. Gabriel Husky and will now
turn the presentation to him welcome sir
thank you for the
action and thank you all who are tuning
in today to listen I'm gonna focus my
talk today on describing how we use
various cell lines from thermo starting
with the freestyle 293 system and now
expanding over the XP show system in our
larger efforts in the field of HIV
vaccine research now the work I will be
showing today as an individual is really
a large collaborative effort at the root
of this a lot of the work that it will
be presented is work done at three
different institutes here in San Diego
at the Scripps La Jolla Institute I work
in a lab lab and reward our primary
technique is electron microscopy we also
work closely with ian wilson who's an
exterior crystallographer so a lot of
the structural biology work is done here
at Scripps
while we collaborate closely with John
Moore over at the Cornell Medical
College New York he is an integral part
in the molecular biology discovery and
isolation of new a munitions and finally
our collaborator rockier Sanders out in
Amsterdam does a lot of the immunology
work also isolation of neutralizing
antibodies topics that will hear about
soon so we're fortunate in this you know
nonprofit Research Institute and also in
the field at large for HIV vaccine
research so there's a high amount of
interest to get a vaccine which with
that comes a lot of labs a lot of
collaborative effort and a lot of
research funding now why is there such
an interest in HIV vaccines well this is
not here estimates the amount of new
cases in the year 2015 so less than two
years ago and globally it's estimated
that they were over two million new
infections of HIV and keep in mind this
is in a day and age where we have
various forms of antiretroviral
medications we have different
programs to help educate and to help try
to prevent the spread of disease even
with all those policies in place we are
unfortunately seeing a rise so as I
mentioned a few years ago total cases in
the world about 36 million but 2 million
new cases that equates to about 4 new
cases every minute of HIV transmission
and it's estimated by multiple agencies
that if we don't ramp up the efforts or
change something now we're gonna see a
rise of another 100 million cases in
about 15 years from now so the one way
we could try to decrease this value and
try completely eradicate it is through
vaccination however this is not a new
concept HIV research and just the
description of it has been around since
the early 80s and of course one of the
first things I researchers try to do
once they discovered that the causative
agent was a virus is to try what we've
done for several other viruses even
bacterial create a vaccine unfortunately
this is a very difficult model to work
with and for various reasons I'll get
those to that in the next few slides now
here I'm showing a diagram of let me
pull out a little pointer we have the
HIV genome here and then a cartoon
representation of the virus I mentioned
that there are many antiretroviral
therapies these days the first one was a
ZT and the mid-90s and that targets an
enzyme called reverse transcriptase
since then there's silver more that's
hard get though
additionally we have medications or
drugs that target integrase and produce
two additional important aspects of the
HIV replication cycle and here quoted
for a row telegraphy er I have the
estimated costs per year
and keep in mind that most patients who
are and on antiretrovirals they're
taking a cocktail of medications so
these are large costs potentially
they're being covered by healthcare in
some parts but in other parts of the
world they're just inaccessible and on
top of that all of these drugs are
targeting aspects of the viral life
cycle that are already after infection
so they're not preventing it or not
preventing they're not eradicating that
the viral loads there's some newer
classes of antibodies and repertory of
antiretroviral medications and this
topic will come into play a little bit
later but they are so-called fusion
inhibitors so they're trying they're
targeting the initial binding of the
virus to the host cell however you know
these are effective at controlling by
uremia hiv-positive patients but they
once again do not eradicate the virus so
we want what we want to do with the
vaccine is target the only surface the
viral protein which is called envelope
it is expressed as one long gene GP 160
or one pro peptide and that's cleaved by
an endogenous enzyme called furin into
two components gp120 and gp41 now on top
of that you know we discussed it's
there's difficulties in making the
vaccine so here are some of the elements
that are a purple for us first of all
HIV is a highly variable virus it
mutates very frequently so this slide
here diagrams roughly to scale the
diversity of different viruses here so
we have at the top left corner the
diversity of the global influenza
strains in one year 1996
so this is across the whole world the
the prevalent that prevalent influenza
strains that were floating around if we
look below that we see almost the same
extent just the diversity
the HIV virus in a single patient six
years after infection so the virus in
individual patients is mutating very
frequently in response to Indian
pressures and also it mutates as it's
spreading from patient to patient we
have a cohort of individuals in the
bottom left this is one year and I don't
have the total number of patients I
believe is in the hundreds so this is
let's say roughly a hundred patients in
one small part of the world in the big
city of Amsterdam large diversity and
then in one year in one region on the
right here we have HIV straight
circulating forums in the Congo in 1997
and in crazy diversity here and these
single letters are subtypes so those are
genetically similar strains of HIV thus
so the first fertile as I mentioned is
the great diversity of HIV
second of all the envelope glycoprotein
on the surface that we would like to
target to try to prevent infection as
heavily glycosylated is one of the most
glycosylated proteins we know in nature
these are all n-linked glycans so they
are attached to asparagine residues
spread throughout the the polypeptide
and in fact it's estimated that roughly
half the mass of this glycoprotein is
contributed from the glycans on the Left
I have a side and top view of this
glycoprotein which assembles as a trimer
once again I'm going to reiterate that
there's two components to it the gp120
portion which is accessible suppose
system should be 41 which is more hidden
and eventually it is what anchors the
lipo protein to the viral membrane
I mentioned the high genetic diversity
and not only is a diverse in individual
patients elsewhere but just globally
around the world and there seems to be
pockets around the world where one
particular subtype is heavily
predominant over others
now genetically we can breakdown HIV
into two major groups hiv-1 and hiv-2
HIV - I'm not going to talk about it's a
very small subset of populations and has
only been isolated in small portions of
the world but HIV one is typically what
we talk about when we talk about global
infections and the most prevalent
pandemic group is this group out here
and that can be broken down into the
various subtypes listed by individual
letters now what I want to bring to
attention is this total global breakdown
here on this pie chart roughly half is
constituted by a subtype C and this is
most prevalent in sub-saharan Africa
historically however the HIV strains
that were being isolated and sequenced
and that became lab adapted strains for
study were taken from patients in
hospitals or research institutes in
North America and Europe which as you
see is dominated by subtype beat so
while we have several sequences and so
we're allowed to opt in strains that we
can study or subtype B they don't
necessarily correspond genetically to
the heaviest hit part of the world in
sub-saharan Africa so one of our desires
is to create immunogen's
that would mimic the various diversity
we see around the world and this is a
reiteration of what I mentioned at the
end like hands on on protein on an
envelope constitute about 50% of the
mass and
the reasoning behind this is that it has
an evolutionary advantage to evade the
immune system and HIV is not the only
lipoprotein bottle direct protein to use
glycans to shield conserved protein
regions here on this bottom arrow I list
several others so we have hemagglutinin
from influenza we have Ebola
glycoprotein we all have HIV envelope
here and we have Corona buyer spikes so
HIV envelope the eighty one is a rough
estimate but from sequence to sequence
the amount of glycans can vary anywhere
from a high 70s to maybe 90 per trimer
and I mentioned the evolutionary
advantage of these like hands as you
know addict wave from the immune system
this chart here looks at addition of
black hands to influenza hemagglutinin
most likely as a response of
evolutionary pressure is due to the
immune system we go back to the late 60s
there's few and linked like hands on the
surface of hemagglutinin and as we go
through the years more and more are
added so we we believe the same
rationale is happening in HIV where it
is black hands offer a protective
advantage for the virus and so that is
one type of evasion mechanism another
problem which will be very important now
when you know we think about expressing
HIV envelope as potential immunogen's
for vaccines is that the protein that
naturally is metastable it is able to or
it easily falls apart where the gp120
and the GP so gp120 we have those kind
of ovals at the top and then the gp41 as
the rank tangles at the bottom those two
components are not covalently linked to
one another so there is some shedding
that occurs some dissociation of gp120
and gp41 which
leads to these gp41 stumps you may also
have trimers other lacking certain
aspects and also trimmers I did not fold
properly either due to insufficient
cleavage or other factors all of these
are highly immunogenic
so in hiv-positive patients the immune
system will direct antibodies towards
these stumps towards these malformed
trimmers towards these aberrant tremors
here that are not fully formed
unfortunately these antibodies are not
protected because these versions of are
not functional so they will not come
into play in the attachment of the virus
to the hosts
so furthermore these trimers are few and
far between on a viral surface is
estimated that each virus has maybe 7 to
14 copies of the tiger so what we are
hoping is to have antibodies against the
functional native-like trimer
that is capable of infection and
hopefully by binding antibodies that
prevents binding of the virus to the
host cell now for a while this was more
of a dream or an ideal than anything but
over the past decade we as a community
have been isolating more and more
antibodies from HIV individuals who we
deem elite controllers these are
individuals who are HIV positive but
there by their prognosis does not
progress towards AIDS and their viral
reloads are relatively low so something
naturally in their blood my body is able
to suppress the Byram iya doesn't
irritate the virus but it prevents the
need even for antiretroviral therapy or
intervention at the time and what's been
discovered is that base of sort of
patients may be 25% produce work called
broadly neutralizing antibodies these
are antibodies that are
only protective against that specific
strain of HIV that infected that
individual but on a larger panel it
prevents in vivo infection of other
genetically diverse screens so because
these patients naturally produced such
antibodies we feel that there should be
a way to recapitulate this in the form
of a vaccine and healthy individuals and
hopefully they will produce half
circulating broadly neutralizing
antibodies that will prevent infection
if they are ever exposed to the virus
this is not a fully comprehensive list
of all the antibodies but I list them
here on this chart in terms of covered
so percent virus's on a panel that would
be neutralized or an infection will be
prevented if you incubate with this
antibody and also the potency on the
x-axis I mentioned early on that our lab
primarily focuses on electron microscopy
one of our advantage of our tools is
that we're able to directly look to see
where on the surface of these envelope
trimers these antibodies bind and map
these epitopes as we've discovered over
the years here there's very few surfaces
that are left on target and now by these
antibodies so before we thought maybe
only the most conservative ones would be
the targets but we're learning that
that's not always the rule now with
electron microscopy where with low
resolution models such as the ones you
see to the right those are quick
experiments to do relatively easily and
they help us determine epitopes
they don't give us but amount of detail
we need to figure out which amino acids
are responsible but they're a good
starting point then what we do in our
lab is we move on to cryo-electron
microscopy which is a high resolution
technique and in recent years it's
overlapping with x-ray crystallography
for the amount of detail on that alloys
Ellucian we're able to get
just as a proof-of-concept this is from
a study years back if you take these
broadly neutralising antibodies and you
put him into macaques or monkeys and
then try to infect them with a viral or
HIV version a high grade that would
infect monkeys you see that there's
protection of these antibodies so high
doses and a medium doses that even at
low doses several animals respond by not
actually becoming infected with the
virus
if we use a control this is I believe
the dengue antibody which does not offer
any protection against HIV all the
animals do get infected so there is a
number of studies that demonstrate these
broad and neutralizing antibodies are
very effective and they can even be used
as alternative to small molecule anti
retrovirals which some groups are
working on but that's independent of our
research so the you know just a recap
we've talked about diversity genetic
diversity of HIV being a big hurdle they
talked about the glycosylation aspect
and I've you know alluded to the
metastability as you know another by ole
decoy and this is the problem here you
know described at the top this
dissociation of the components of the
trainer you know gp120 here gp41 leaves
open you know these surfaces that are
normally packed against one another
they're not accessible to the new system
now all of a sudden they're available to
the immune system they're highly
immunogenic you'll get a great immune
response you'll get antibodies against
them but they once again it won't be
protective because they don't bind to
the version of the trimer that is
necessary for infecting new cells now of
course this is a big protein engineering
problem here if our natural protein is
falling apart
it's going to be hard to put this into a
vaccine what
collaborators specifically starting with
John Moore over in New York going back
to the early 2000s they came up with a
clever idea on how to make this into a
form that we can actually use here's a
schematic of the envelope peptide the
gp120 is this cyan and orange region
here and on to the left there's constant
regions list of the sieve there's a
variable region used by variable regions
listed as B and beyond that we have gp41
here we have in red this membrane
proximal terminal region and we have
this transmembrane domain and a
c-terminal domain which is thought to be
on the inside of the virus so we're
doing with a number of issues first this
detachment of gp120 from gp41 so let me
clear this our collaborators were able
to address this by introducing a
disulfide bond that links gp120
to gp41 and the great thing about this
disulfide bond is still allows for the
cleavage by the fear and enzyme to occur
we find in our studies our structural
studies that if the cleavage does not
occur these primers do not fold into
their native life state that is capable
of infection so we have a disulfide the
two won't separate from each other
because we're covalently linked but the
cleavage still occurs for proper folding
second they introduce simple isoleucine
Napolean mutation which gp41 region and
this prevents the HeLa C's in that
region which during the fusion process
do elongate we want to keep them in
their pre fusion state so this prolene
adds essentially a kink that keeps the
energy minimum in the pre fusion states
and finally they've been able to
truncate at this residue six explore
here so this is before all of the
hydrophobic membrane Proximus terminal
region and trans number domains
SOI belies these i once again recap this
is a crystal structure here of these
engineered envelope tremors that we use
so sip is the term that you may hear
throughout this presentation and that
signifies the SOS linkage so the
disulfide and the NIDA P mutation so
these sorts of tremors once again we
have gp120 gp41 intact they're
covalently linked so we shouldn't say
that shedding that the buyers naturally
does and we want to ensure that
everything else is in its natural state
these v1 v2 loops are kind of at the
apex of the trimer
there's been many neutralizing
antibodies discovering that target out
region so we want to make sure it's
presented properly we also want to
include this b3 loop it's tucked in
right here underneath that b1 b2
it tends to be immunodominant and
immunogenic
however those antibodies generally do
not offer protection against infection
so we want to make sure that's nicely
sequestered in there and finally we want
where you know we keep good towels on
the glycans want to present them as
naturally as possible
and as a proof of concept we've done
several immunization studies throughout
the years to demonstrate that these
social trimers compared to other designs
which have removed that cleavage site
are superior in terms of immune response
so the three here on this chart this is
the amount the titers of neutralization
or antibodies that are able to
neutralize the parent virus that these
munitions were based on the three with
the largest success were the social
designs from two different strains of B
41 B G 505 those are from subtype a
subtype beef and all these other designs
that rely on deleting the the cleavage
site
or introducing a fold on trimerization
domain I did not offer the same level of
protection so our group and in
collaboration with the others mentioned
we have this iterative process you know
at the core because we are electron
microscopy lab we are able to evaluate
these trimers by electron microscopy so
anything we're expressing and from now
on most of the work I will show will be
from the freestyle 293 system later it
will compare it to recent efforts Beck
speech show so what we expressed in
house or beer collaborators in the 293
system we're able to examine by electron
microscopy but even before that you know
we do sizes in chromatography to see the
relative ratio of trimer formation
versus dimer and monomer protein
stability DSC an idea surfaced
techniques and then of course antigenic
profiles what we care about here is that
the proteins we express that they are
capable of binding to brought in tracing
antibodies but they limit the binding of
non neutralizing antibodies and finally
before any kind of clinical studies or
animal studies we like to do some types
of stress tests to see the stability of
these primers under various conditions
this is a very brief overview of the
assessment we quickly do by NIT by
electron microscopy specifically the
technique is negative stain electron
microscopy we have these small copper
grids on which we've deposited a thin
layer nitrocellulose that's in great
here that's also coated with carbon to
help adsorb proteins we put our protein
sample down we add a heavy metal stain
we blot it off and we can store it in
these grid boxes until we're ready to
collect data when we collect data this
is a representative micrograph so the
way this negative stain works is that it
will prevent the transmission of
electrons through this grid everywhere
that were there stain deposited but
you have protein particles they tend to
include that stain so the electron beam
transmits to them and the particles
appears white so even just looking at
this micrograph if you squint your eyes
you'll see protein particles that appear
to have a trimeric shape to them we're
able to do some automated particle
picking and then we can extract those
particles and if you look at just the
individual particles there tends to be
at different levels of noise
signal-to-noise some of these do not you
know even represent the tremors yet but
through computational algorithms were
able to group these together into ones
that share similar features rotate them
translate them and create what we call
class averages so here we have you know
more defined because each of these
subsets you're averaging a beam between
50 and 100 of these particles now why we
do this you know through our experience
we've noticed that there is a
correlation between trimers expressed
rhymers or engineered travelers that
offer the correct antigenic profile and
then furthermore a good immune response
versus those that lack that we find that
the the trimers that work best have this
kind of closed conformation which we
call native-like there is no sign of the
trauma falling apart it looks like all
three of these gp120 s from this top
view are interacting with one another we
also see some degree of flexibility over
all the central density here is still
trimeric but these extra densities on
the side it may suggest that some of the
domains are moving around and the
non-native trimers tend to look like
this you may have you know with the
three gp120 s but they're not associated
with one another they're splayed out but
because they're covalently attached that
gp41 they're still tethered to it but do
not adopt this closed compact state here
and on top of that as i mentioned we've
been able to look at various antibodies
bound to these trimers
coupled with this through other
collaborators specifically maps Crispin
at Oxford University they use mass
spectrometry to really analyze the
flycam profile of these primers and the
main take-home message here is these are
expressed in mammalian cells or human
cells if we're using heck 293 F or you
know mammalian a hat hamster if we're
using the Cho system so we would expect
from a glidecam processing standpoint
that all of them linked like hands
should adopt a complex like an mica form
what is unique about HIV is that there
are so many glycans and in regions that
are so heavily so dense
someone next to each other but they are
actually preventing some of these like
and processing enzymes from getting in
there and having access so what we find
is that there's a high degree of glycans
that still are the high Manus or illegal
mannose premature form most of those are
located in the gp120 region and are
shown here in green we have more exposed
like hands that don't have to me
neighboring ones that are processed into
complex ones and pink and then an orange
our hybrid ones where they're not still
haven't fully gone downstream and on top
of that we my already alluded to the
fact that cleavage is important for
proper tremor formation and we've been
able to show that by electron microscopy
some of these the top panel here is our
source of design where we allow cleavage
to occur but we have that engineered
disulfide an IEP mutation and if we
start removing some of those regions or
if we start putting in just the SC KS
removes the cleavage site you see more
and more of these phenotypes that are
aberrant trimers display token
additionally you know we we feel
we should be preserving the glycan
forums as well as possible to that of
the native virus but if we do not
engineer our proteins a correct way that
has a strong influence on the
glycosylation processing and the story
here is once again if we take our social
design those close compact rhymers we
get a like a form that is predominantly
high man ups if we instead look at the
primers that are splayed open and just
tethered by that disulfide bond we see
more and more glycan processing more of
the complex glycans which do not
necessarily represent what is on the
surface of the virus and therefore does
not represent what that mean system sees
and on top of that our purification
scheme for these primaries varies from
concept to construct and this will come
into play very soon when we talk about
XP show but there's three different
purification schemes I would like to
address here there's two g12
this was the original anti-body we used
for purifying these trimers it binds to
a high Manos like Han patch on a surface
of gp120 so this antibody isolated from
became an individual actually targets
the glycans because it's so different
from human bike oscillation due to the
density and immature form of the bike
ends we're able to use this to purify
the trimers it would be a more selective
type of lectin purification so to say
because it's specifically against HIV
but it does not discriminate between
dimer monomer trimer we also use PG 145
which is an antibody that binds the apex
and it specifically binds to trimers so
we can select for at the correct America
state there and PGT 151 also binds the
primers but it will it binds at the
interface between gp120 and gp41 and it
will only bind if that fear and cleavage
has occurred
so we have you know some of these are
highly selective and we use them
depending on the screen we're expressing
because not all of them are amenable
which each form that is some of them
rely on they bring glycans so we'll come
back to this in a little bit and the
choice of like sorry the choice of
purification
especially the affinity step does matter
I hear we published a a paper where we
show you know we're using the for some
trickier social constructs if we choose
the less selective to g12
we get a mixture of maybe 50% of the
trimers peer native like the rest do not
if we instead choose the PT 145 which
only selects for trimers we get close to
100% and if we choose less stringent
techniques such as a COS tag in nickel
nta sec most of the proteins look like
aberrant trimers i'm going to quickly go
through these slides because they're not
as pertinent here but they do tie in to
the story that we want to reproduce
recapitulate the proper guy like
oscillation as much as we can because
some of the glycans are highly
consistent in their both their presence
and also the blanket form and they are
the target of certain broadly
neutralising antibodies so therefore
it's important that we keep the right
leg up on there hopefully in a naive
individual they will be able to produce
antibodies that target similar epitope
that relies on these neighboring by
camps and others are variable as i
mentioned over the course of infection
the virus mutates quite quickly due to
if they mean pressures so what the
immune system initially sees will be
different from what it sees two years
later this is something we keep in mind
in our immunization studies because the
germline antibodies are the precursors
to these broadly neutralizing antibodies
probably bound to a version of the
trimer that is different from the one
that mature broad utilizing anybody
binds to so
this idea that we should investigate
sequential immunizations as long as we
have information a longitudinal studies
of the viral evolution it is something
we can do so now actually going into
what we need how we're doing it and new
things we're trying we need for our
studies not just in our lab but in our
collaborations recombinant antibodies
you know I alluded a lot to studying
broadly neutralizing antibodies so we
need those both for our assays to
validate our proteins or immunogen's but
we also need them for our structural
studies both neutralizing and naturally
noxious link in our lives because we
want to screen against both and both IgG
and fragment antigen binding or fab
forms the fab forums tend to be more
amenable to structural determination
because there's less you remove the
flexibility of the hinge region with the
FC portion and of course the biggest
part of our studies are the soluble on
trimers we use untagged versions for
immunizations and animals but we also
create labeled ones that we can bind to
our probes whether we're doing SPR Eliza
or octet
requirements okay so going back the
other the requirements part of this work
you know we we have stable proteins so
you know we're able to do that through
our engineering scheme we want
native-like oscillation so we are
adamant about using mammalian cells for
this work and the quantities required
you know are important to factor in here
so if we just talk about antibodies
because this is the easier aspect of it
antibodies are fats if we want to do our
octet read you know bio Larimer wrong
tree system we generally expect that we
will need about a hundred micrograms of
hg or fab to do 196 well based acid so
these are reasonable quantities
relatively easy to obtain regardless of
the system we're using for structural
determination we might require up to one
milligram in this case of fat so once
again these are not you know extremely
difficult quantities to obtain using the
freestyle 293 f system which we were
using up to this point and we'll talk
about a little bit why we're switching
but for a more elaborate experience
there's some animal studies where we
would like to the study immune
trafficking throughout of the immunogen
to germinal centers or the immune system
and for that we require intact IgG and
we're estimating that for a full study
and monkeys in considering all the
groups we might need close to a gram of
IgG this is a large amount so how do we
express these things in our lab first of
all we transfect into either hag to 93
°f or XP show we've been using two to
one ratios of heavy chain to light chain
either for the IgG or the fab these were
values that seemed to work well for our
collaborators initially
to be honest we haven't played around
with it much more beyond that because of
the yields were we getting we were happy
with them and and like I said either
Tecton i3f which we've typically been
expressing for six days prior harvesting
also when we started doing this we were
using Pei it was for us a cheaper
alternative than the 2/9 reflectance
system and our yields were at least
fifty percent of what we could obtain
with 290 vecten so at that point it was
cost-effective to switch now we're also
experimenting with XP Cho system for
antibodies we're using following the max
titer protocol and harvesting up to two
weeks post transactions we purify these
mostly by protein a resin or some type
of map select if it's an IgG using our
fpse systems in the lab if it's a fab we
have kappa selector landis like columns
against the cap or lambda light chains
and generally we're also purifying goes
over a mono s cation exchange column in
order to remove any light chain dimers
that may have formed so how do these
compare like I mentioned originally we
were using the heck 2/9 we have system
with Pei I'll say on average and it
varies from and I might add an antibody
and I also include that one of the
variations is probably due to different
vectors being used oftentimes we're not
designing the genes here or popping them
into vectors another lab has already
done that so they send us a plasmid and
we assume that it's going to be good
enough for a lot so on average per liter
of culture we were getting about 10
milligrams of recombinant IgG at best
maybe 25 for fab generally less we think
it's more of a expression issue of the
light chain and the heavy chain binding
together without having that FC portion
to help out
but nonetheless we could probably get
about five milligrams per liter now
we're using the XP show system so I
speak show system following all the
reagents and the manufacturers protocol
on average we're getting about 310
milligrams of IgG per liter so that's an
increase anywhere from ten to thirty
five times what we were getting with the
tune a3f system in some cases with one
liter we're almost hitting that one gram
mark that we were estimating we might
need for some of these fancier
immunization experiments and it's funny
to think you know maybe a year ago less
than a year ago we were thinking about
you know something like that we would
have to outsource do elsewhere now it's
something we can easily do in our lab
just by switching over to this
expression system for fabs similar story
in general about ten times higher yields
than what we're seeing there's been some
experimentation trying to use the PC DNA
three-point-four vector from thermo to
see if that can increase our yields even
more our initial experience is that we
might get another 20% boost from it in
terms of total yield but in not in all
cases that we examine looking at code on
optimization or the specific cell lines
we're using so there's still a good
amount of work that can go in here and
the fab yields do suffer after mono less
there just seemed to be some
precipitation but that's independent of
the saw line used so in general for any
type of antibody whether it's fab or
intact IgG we are extremely happy
switching over this platform because
we're able to make you know at least ten
times more and usually more than that so
what can we do with this increase in the
expression using speech oh well I'm
estimating here that you know if we take
an average of 310 milligrams of IgG from
a leader transaction that's 3100 octet
experiments so
or one antibody we could probably make a
stock freeze it and for the next decade
or so in our lab anyone who wants to
study the binding of that or the
kinetics of that specific antibody to
any new trimers made can be using the
same stock without having to express it
again obviously we don't need such large
quantities for wants to speak anybody
but here diversity matters there are
several different broadly neutralising
appellees several non neutralizing
antibodies so if we can cut this you
know do 100 milliliter transmissions at
ten times more diversity that's great
also these affinity columns that I
mentioned before the 2g 12pt 145 PT 1 G
1 that we used to purify trimers we
generally a couple about 20 milligrams
to sepharose port B so we can generate
15 new columns that we use in a gravity
flow and peristaltic pump format this is
great these columns have you know the
high binding capacity for about two
years and then they need to be replaced
this allows us you know with one
expression to literally give everyone in
the lab at their own column if we wanted
to go that route and like I said it's
not for one of these immune trafficking
experiments and the caps that we're
proposing now with the amount of fab we
can get 30 milligrams let's say on
average that's 30 cryo-em structures 330
kratom structures are the same antibody
might be redundant
so let's you know Express smaller
volumes and make 30 fabs now we have 30
unique cryo-em structures which is great
for a lot like this that relies on
publishing new and novel complexes about
300 octet experiments and what I like to
iterate is that we're getting these
large boosts yield but we're also saving
costs so I've estimated that using the
XP Cho system and the average yields
were getting for IgG that expression it
is one third the cost of if we did this
with hectare 93 F plus Pei
partly due to consumables the flaps the
DNA everything going into it and this
does not include labor cost it's
actually you know much faster to purify
these when you do smaller scales they'll
get the same amount of material so we'll
tie everything up at the end but for
antibodies we are very happy in our
experience and not just our lab but John
Moores lab at Cornell Medical College
and also right here Sanders is lab in
Amsterdam
they've all been working with this XP
Cho system now after our success so it
is our go to one for antibodies related
to HIV research now so suppose the trick
here we mentioned metastability like
oscillation all of these other factors
what we need for our typical octet
experiment is anywhere from 200
micrograms to a full milligram of this
dose of trainer for social determination
roughly same amounts and typical
immunization experiments for one
specific type genotype of associate
trimer of anywhere up to 5 milligrams
depending on how many groups of animals
we're using and what types of animals
these are also expressed traditionally
in either pack 2 9 3 up system or XP
coat and here we're transported 1 ratios
of the Sosa plasmid but also a DNA
plasmid encoding for the fear in protein
I mentioned this is endogenous so it's
naturally expressed in human cells but
due to the over expression of Sosa it
can't keep up so if we run gels
afterwards SDS page gels we see that
cleavage is not efficiently occurring
between gp120 and gp41 unless we Co
transfected with additional fear
49 3f similar process to what we were
doing for the ihe G's six days post
transmission harvesting Forex before
expecto we've tried a couple different
things generally following standard
protocol I've tried the high titer one
it didn't help with this aspect and we
generally harvest seven days post
transfection upwards of ten and our
collaborator finds that adding a second
feed on day five even if we're not
following the max or high titer
protocols helps get us higher yields
append we're purifying these over the
three anti-hiv affinity columns and sly
substitution chromatography to isolate
just pure trimer no aggregate no dimer
monomer so here's a comparison now from
how we were doing it how it is an expert
show I would say that there's a modest
improvement and had 293 F on average
we're getting maybe 0.75 or 750
micrograms per liter of transaction now
we don't measure directly total
expression of transcription levels what
we think is occurring is that we are
getting high levels of expression but
only a small subset is actually forming
into the trimers that we are interested
in isolating if we go to X big show we
can get maybe upwards of 5 milligrams
per liter by using the system so we see
a fold increase 5 to 7 times of what we
were getting using 293 F now I have
mentioned the lower yields the
complexity of this protein heavily
glycosylated that could be just a
natural issue and it's such a unique
protein that it's hard to compare to you
know other things in the field
we've had some anomalies at first
observed by our collaborators that if
they chose to use this PT 145 column
which binds at the top of the trimer
they were noticing lower yields if they
put XP geomaterial over this column
compared to 2g 12 we haven't seen this
before if we use show stable selling so
these are so lines are stable
transparent
with the source of gene so it seems to
be something different in the XP Cho
system our hypothesis has been that that
special levels are so fast and so rapid
that maybe we aren't getting proper like
at processing for some critical sugars
that are involved in PT 145 binding but
our solution to this has been to either
increase amount of resin or do batch
binding or a double pass for columns so
collaborator was able to split a 300
middle XP Cho transmission into two one
heated over the two t12 column single
pass when he did over a 145 column
double pass which was packed with more
beads final yields are about the same so
there does seem to be something that is
affecting the the binding possibly the
increasing off rates of the source of
trimer to this PDT 145 antibody if we
are expressing an XP joke
however our workaround is to increase
the amount of resin or batch binding
versus regulated flow overnight now I
mentioned the modest increase five to
seven times the way I would say this to
is I keep mentioning we're interested in
diversity the the HIV virus is also high
amount of diversity we're trying to
create a vaccine that would be useful in
different parts of the world that tend
to be infected by genetically diverse
genotypes of HIV to other parts so it's
imperative that we test a lot of
different so sips based on a lot of
different designs and in our incubators
or suit incubators generally with Hector
a3f we're doing one liter transparency
liter flasks and we're able to fit
roughly eight at one time also loading a
leader over these columns at slow volume
it takes multiple days with xpeke so we
can reasonably you know cut down our
volume by a temp and do 32 constructs at
the same time so this is advantageous if
we want to quickly screen through
different designs by octet and other
studies and it would still give us
enough potentially to even try some a.m.
work
this so what I've estimated too is
because of you know less consumables
we're able to test me before times as
many variables or different so sipped
trimers using XP Cho system for about a
cost that's half as much as our sorry
for it cost us less than two times the
cost of the coolant t9 3f transcription
so it's a little more expensive but you
can get more done at a time so once
again the goal here is to increase the
diversity of potential immunogen's it's
better for us to screen more in a one
month period than have to do that over a
six month period and it's a fast moving
field so this is where I see an
advantage of using the system so finally
I'd like to conclude in terms of
antibody production we've essentially
completely switched over to XP Cho I I
would highly recommend it it saves money
and you get more out of it and different
types of antibodies
whether it's IgG or fab ones that
express worse and others we've had
successful for all of them so that's the
the greatest aspect of this and for
sources of expression as I mentioned
it's gonna be case by case this is a
difficult protein to work with but if
we're interested in diversity over a
short period of time it is a feasible
way of us doing that so like to quickly
thank members of my lab my mentor and
reward so all the key players in our
research and other labs that I mentioned
the Wilson lab more lab Sanders lab our
funding comes from multiple sources and
IH Grant's Bill and Melinda Gates
Foundation I a B and iid all you know
working towards HIV vaccine research and
finally I like to give a shout out to
Isla Moody and Rick Bosque for
encouraging me to present my findings
today to the audience so I will now take
any questions so thank you
research we will now start the live Q&A
portion if you have any questions to ask
please do so now just click on the green
Q&A button at the lower left of the
presentation window type your questions
into the box but appear on that screen
and then click the send button will
answer as many questions as we have time
for what is the next step in optimizing
the external expression of hiv-1 for
others so sorry okay so I think the
important aspect to really look at is to
go back to the genetics the gene design
I mentioned that several times were
getting plasmids from other
collaborators but I think it's critical
if wanna boost the yields even more
beyond well we've initially seen to
better design our vectors choose the
best expression vectors for the correct
cell lines whatever do a next week's
show or to 9:30 F and code on
optimization all of that so I think
that's the next step but also taking
another look at total amount of DNA and
DNA plasmid ratios during transmission
you know I mentioned we're in a
fast-moving field a lot of times we're
excited to try these new methodologies
new techniques new reagents and we jump
into it we have some success we can
definitely optimize it and I think we
just need to go back to the drawing
board have some a few people devoted to
testing those variables
thank you for your answer there's
another howdy to trimmers produced intro
verses pet - 9 3 F compare in terms of
yeah that's an important question we are
just beginning to look at the
immunogenicity of XP co-produced trimers
but based on our previous experience by
expressing in show stable cell lines we
did not see any difference in control
studies in macaques whether we produce
the same trimer in the 293 f platform
versus cho both responded well in terms
of the immune response second we
generally do not see a difference in a
thermal stability if you run BSC nano
DSF roughly the same amount and on top
of that the antigenicity profiles seem
to be very comparable
I would like to finally add that we are
collaborating to have one of these early
designs or the one of the initial source
of designs large-scale production GMP
scale for human clinical trials and that
type of work will be expressed in show
saw lens so we have confidence that the
two are interchangeable for our work
thank you for those answers
unfortunately we have no more time for
questions but additional questions will
be answered and published on Thermo
Fisher Scientific website you will
receive an email notification when
answers are available I'd like to take
the time to thank laberd's and give a
part of Thermo Fisher Scientific for
making today's educational webcast
possible before we go I want to remind
everyone that today's webcast will be
available on-demand viewing through
April 2018 you'll receive an email from
a branch letting you know that the
webcast will be available for replay
please share this announcement with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
event that's all for now enjoy the rest
of the conference hope to see you again
goodbye